ida ida works as a translator for the
united nations in srebrenica which has
recently been invaded by serbian forces
her family is one of hundreds seeking
protection
ida faces a dilemma can she use her
position to help her family and her
people
the winner of the lux audience award is
chosen by the public and members of the
european parliament
them
the three nominees for the 2022 lux
audience award have been announced
flea is an animated documentary telling
the true story of amin an afghan refugee
who came to denmark alone as a teenager
now years later he confronts a secret
from his past
great freedom takes place in post-war
germany when homosexuality was a crime
hans is put in prison for being gay
while there a relationship slowly
develops between him and his cellmate
victor
[Music]
works as a translator for the united
nations in srebrenica which has recently
been invaded by serbian forces her
family is one of hundreds seeking
protection
ida faces a dilemma can she use her
position to help her family and her
people
the winner of the lux audience award is
chosen by the public and members of the
european parliament
10
the three nominees for the 2022 lux
audience award have been announced
flee is an animated documentary telling
the true story of amin an afghan refugee
who came to denmark alone as a teenager
now years later he confronts a secret
from his past
great freedom takes place in post-war
germany when homosexuality was a crime
hans is put in prison for being gay
while there a relationship slowly
develops between him and his cellmate
victory
[Music]
ida works as a translator for the united
nations in srebrenica which has recently
been invaded by serbian forces her
family is one of hundreds seeking
protection
ida faces a dilemma can she use her
position to help her family and her
people
the winner of the lux audience award is
chosen by the public and members of the
european parliament
[Music]
president mitzola ladies and gentlemen
those in the chamber as well as those
joining us virtually welcome to the
award ceremony of looks the european
audience film award by the european
parliament and the european film academy
in partnership with the european
commission and europa cinemas the
nominations for looks the european
audience film award 2022 are
flee directed by jonas poger rasmussen
great freedom directed by sebastian
maiser
[Applause]
and
anguo vadi saeeda directed by yasmine
banich
please welcome representing the danish
french swedish and norwegian
co-production flee director jonas pohar
rasmussen as well as producer monica
hellstrom
representing the austrian and german
co-production great freedom director
sebastian miza as well as producer
sabina moser
[Applause]
and finally representing the
co-production from bosnia and
herzegovina austria netherlands france
poland
norway germany romania and turkey kuo
vadi saeeda director and producer
yasmina spanich and manira subasic
president of the mothers of srebrenica
association and survivor of the shred
beneath the genocide
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests welcome to the lux
audience award
i am very pleased to welcome the
directors and the producers of the three
powerful films shortlisted for this
year's lux audience award i sincerely
congratulate them and you for your films
work studied
already and rightly so with glory and
success we are honored that our partners
from the european film academy the
european commission and europe cinemas
could join us too
i truly hope that you will remember your
nomination for the luxe audience award
as something unique in a prolonged
cinematic career going forward
this lux audience award
is unique it is the only cinema prize
awarded by a parliament
both members of the european parliament
as well as european citizens are allowed
to cast their vote from across 27
european union member states
nominated lux award films are subtitled
in 24 languages
screened over 400 times in all the
european union member states and
multiple debates are organized around
them between cinema lovers members of
the european parliament and film
industry professionals
with the lux audience award the european
parliament shows its support for
european creativity and excellence in
filmmaking and the european parliament
stands clearly for freedom of expression
in film for directors storytellers and
authors alike
the lux audience award builds bridges
between our political work and the
creative work of filmmakers in europe
lux films echo through art the sentiment
of the fight for civil rights human
rights justice democracy and freedom
and it is wonderful that many of lux
audience award winners from 2021 as well
as from 2022 are with us here today in
strasbourg
the three luxe award nominees share a
common message
the struggle for freedom a fundamental
value of the european union
i welcome yonaspohe rasmussen director
of flee
who presents the incredibly moving film
that tells the extraordinary but true
story of amin
a child refugee from afghanistan who
escapes his country in order to live in
freedom
this extremely touching story makes us
wonder
how many amines are out there seeking to
flee injustice and persecution
i welcome sebastian myself director of
great freedom
who shows us that the end of world war
ii
was not a liberation for everyone
criminal law outlawed homosexuality in
the years following 1945
this film
pays homage to all those who fought
discrimination
based on sexual orientation and who
wished to live in freedom
i welcome yasmina yasmilas banich
director of cuavades aida
who offered another view on the
suffering of people during the 1995
srebrenica genocide
this film
is a strong call for justice
for the women
and mothers of srebrenica who witnessed
the atrocious killing of over 8 000
loved ones
such horrendous atrocities and such a
crime against humanity must never be
forgotten
and ladies and gentlemen may i invite
you to applaud here with us today the
president of the association of the
mothers of srebrenica and the survivor
of the genocide miss munira subasic we
are honored
[Applause]
we are honored truly honored that you
can be here with us today in this house
of democracy and freedom all three
shortlisted films draw from historical
events but their subjects are extremely
topical today as we know too well about
the disasters of an ongoing war in
ukraine and the plight of displaced
people forced to flee for their safety
at the risk of falling victims of other
horrors on land and at sea ladies and
gentlemen dear directors be assured that
the message of your powerful films has
been received and that the european
parliament will always be with you on
the side of liberty freedom and human
rights you are an inspiration to the
world of film thank you for what you do
[Applause]
mrs sabina verhayan member of the
european parliament and chair of
parliament's committee on culture and
education will now present the award for
the third place nominee
ladies and gentlemen
this is the exciting moment when we
discover who has won the third prize
of the lux audience award
and i announced that the third prize was
one by sebastian mizer for great freedom
[Applause]
um
vice president evelyn reakner will now
present the award for the second place
nominee
getting exciting uh
again more exciting
and
the
second
prize goes to flee from jonas paula
rasmussen congratulations
[Applause]
thank
chair
so it falls to me now to announce the
lux prize audience award
for
2022 and the winner
is corvadis ida yasmilas baniche
[Applause]
your excellencies ladies and gentlemen i
would
ladies and gentlemen your excellencies
it's been 27 years since the genocide in
srebrenica i survived the genocide
22 members of my immediate family were
killed in the genocide my husband my
youngest son
whom i loved
dearly i buried two of his bones
i begged
dear god
to make sure that mothers never
experienced what we experienced i prayed
to dear god that no mother would ever
look for her son's bones again but while
i'm speaking here unfortunately in
ukraine mothers are crying looking for
the bones of their sons
they're crying
russian mothers are crying too because
it's their children who went to either
be killers or to be killed so i beg of
you stop the war in ukraine
stop so that as few mothers in the world
as possible suffer please stop the
suffering the suffering of a single
mother is hard enough thank you once
again thank you all
who have voted for this film
the summer
i just i just want to say another thing
the worst thing in the world is to wait
for justice and we have been waiting for
it for 27 years
we've been waiting for it for 27 years
thank you
strong duty to tell these stories at
that moment when i was
preparing film about genocide in
srebrenica i was thinking that uh war in
bosnia croatia in our region is the last
one in europe
i was so shocked to to learn that we
europeans allowed war in ukraine that we
didn't find a way how to negotiate and
that war never
happens i really
urge you all to find ways to stop the
war in ukraine as you can see
this is
huh
because it will be the next one thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dear colleagues can i ask you to take
your seats
[Music]
you